what else would a Korean person say I
must
remind someone you're like assault
uncivilized always stealing every day
I'm supervised you could have unlocked
car in South Korea nobody's gonna steal
it
[Music]
so you guys been hearing about the Kia
and Hyundai crime wave yes pretty
pervasive yeah everywhere you made the
USB key thing yeah yep my neighbor's car
got stolen so to catch people up right
can die they're able to easily steal
these cars using a little USB method and
they just go in do it they're in and out
very fast it's happening it's a crime
wave all over the world right now
um when it comes to Kias and Hyundais
and
some people
have chosen to blame Kia and Hyundai for
this what what I thought the state of
California was suing them uh Seattle is
I think that's crazy Seattle California
is suing them now dude the blames are
funny like some people are just flat out
blaming Tick Tock or like the police are
blaming Tick Tock I blame the people
they should just all buy Mercedes
Korean like car manufacturer and you're
like wait it's our fault that the cars
are stolen
but it's like well that is what they're
arguing so there's a there's an opinion
you should have realized Americans were
a bunch of crooks and made better
security systems why'd you make it so
easy for them to steal it but USPS
Korean yeah whole Koreans are in trouble
dude yep that's the one now they took
you know yeah they're like so that's the
argument right I didn't know everybody's
gonna be stealing every day here in
Hyundai not the public should bear the
cost of their irresponsible decision to
sell cars without immobilizers what
they're creating unsafe products
costs of their decision have reached
have far-reaching effects on Public
Safety we don't have a burglars like you
guys so we don't even know that this
exists
keep going I want more what else would a
Korean person say
[Laughter]
I'm like a car in South Korea nobody's
gonna steal it
makes it that's my next question because
all the
in Korea where there's probably the most
Hyundai's in case I would imagine does
anybody steal them there no no they only
have Mercedes out there they only sell
those they don't like you want to hunt
that though yeah I haven't had one
stolen yet because there's still that
piece of [__] damn Koreans love Lexus
and Mercedes they don't even buy their
own car so what Kia and Hyundai have
done to try and stem the thefts they
have a software update they say fixes
the issue with the USB but it requires a
visit to the dealer and takes up to 45
minutes to install they also have
started giving police departments
anti-theft steering wheel locks to hand
out to affected like the club yes like
the club that's already been like
that's that's a freaking hacksaw fix
away is it a defect Brian's waffles but
that's like that was already yeah
Ryan's like you guys don't have hacksaws
yeah get a [__] hacksaw you idiots
great right once I give you the software
upgrade they put a little sticker in the
window that that basically tells Steve's
they're going to waste their time on
this car
because we already got the upgrade
stickers out so it's like brings home
security you just get the sign even if
you don't pay for them I bet that does
work though you know it must like it
stops people that is still gonna get
your window broken yeah yeah it is crazy
that it's the blame is on the automaker
you know what though that's pretty
enough because I think like
I get it if it was unsafe driving like
yeah you need to recall this [__]
airbag because it blows up in people's
faces or like you know like if it's if
it's like this Tire's [__] up or
whatever
that makes sense because the purpose for
it is to be driven that's it but then if
it's like
the anti-theft device isn't good enough
or whatever I just don't get why that's
the mess like if it's already anti-theft
like it locks right yeah but then now
you need like some crate like some extra
level because the culture at the country
is [__] crazy let me push let me push
back so we
all I think all of us have Ledger Nano s
is like our Ledger devices to protect
our cryptos right and if there was a
vulnerability or a flaw that hackers are
now exploring wouldn't we not blame
Legends yeah of course we would and so
because this vulnerability existed in
these vehicles and they made it so easy
for thieves to steal is it not on them
as well but a vehicle is not like I
don't get the purpose of a vehicle for
it to be like a safe yeah I don't lock
my valuables in there or like like a a
safe like the purpose of it is like a
bank a bank vault but when you hit lock
on your car don't you have an
expectation that your car this should
hold up yeah right and I think that
that's the expectation the consumer has
when they're purchasing the vehicle
especially when they're paying how much
for these cars it's the uh it's an
exploit and then and if one guy can
teach the next guy and that just becomes
the thing because if have you seen the
videos of people doing it it's super
easy it is super easy you take out the
steering column panel block pull this
[__] out plug this [__] in and then you
can turn it that's too easy see even
like to the standard of like 90s car
theft that's two and I'm not saying like
the you know there's thieves out there
or even like locksmith guys who are
probably laughing at this anyway because
they could easily get into any car right
yeah yeah but that's a different
conversation than this vulnerability
that anybody can exploit I mean these
are like 14 year old kids doing it yeah
you don't need the skill set right you
don't have to like build that skill up
to go swipe a car it's kids that can't
steal any other card that's got to be a
different problem you know what I mean
but what a rush they feel though huh oh
yeah they turn that [__] thing and it
goes on how do they get in they can get
in the car with the USB no you just bust
the car if you break the window first
but you but then if you rip the steer
well I don't [__] get more Kia stolen
I see well you know there was something
no it's so easy
there was something really like similar
to this in the 90s where it was super
easy by having something called the G
key so when you had a master key like a
dealership would have a master key for
all the Camrys or Toyotas or whatever
right and it's one key fits all for all
the cars uh what they would do is like
thieves and whatever would basically
find access to a GQ whether it's like
they steal it from the dealership or
they have a shady guy at the dealership
make them a copy or whatever and then
you were able to just break into cars
and turn it on and leave but that's like
I don't know if that's the
manufacturer's fault because it's being
exploited you know what I mean like the
GQ was over the master key wasn't met
the hands of themes but also too like if
you were the [__] president of
Hyundai or Kia and you saw this popping
off wouldn't you be like man we should
try to fix this I think if your sales
are going down fix the problem yeah yeah
because at that point yeah I think
that's the that would be the question is
like
how fast did they act
and is it too late for the cars that
already are in circulation also I think
it depends on like where the line of
responsibility is like if it's like you
go up to a car you can just open the car
door only starting from the entry of the
car yeah that's the car maker they
[__] up but if it takes bashing a
window clearing the glass doing all of
that and then getting in so it takes
like a burglar to get into the car then
I'm like I don't know if that's then
it's like the responsibility that's on
the car maker gets reduced reduce reduce
so that's what the big corporations are
saying as well it's just super easy
[Laughter]
is saying that the city's lawsuits are
without Merit arguing basically it's
like they have their hand up Bart's ass
saying exactly the same thing uh arguing
that Federal Auto Safety Regulators do
not require automakers to install
immobilizers on their vehicles that is
basically just a device they make sure
you're using the exact right key when
you click the click ignition right yeah
um so it's they're saying that's not on
them I understand that
all the alarms
because I see it in the same vein of
like let's say I buy a a helmet right
if I ride a bike I fall off and then I
hit my head and my [__] skull cracks
open
that might be the helmet's fault if I
ride a bike I do a triple back flip off
the Queen Mary land on the sidewalk and
then my skull cracks open I'm like dude
you gotta make better helmets I don't
know I think might be on me
I really don't think but that's that's
such like a unique user Case by case no
but this guy's these guys are breaking
into the cars already it doesn't matter
what Electronics yeah but but the fact
that there is a specific exploit where
like all people are stealing this like
every car is getting because if this is
breaking the car they have a skill set
to do it you can just walk in the car
because why aren't these kids doing this
to Teslas why don't they breaking
Windows of Teslas because they can't
there's no export why are they doing
that to Rams or Mercedes but then that's
what I mean like that means Tesla's
above the average car the same way that
KIA is below the average that's why I
think like they should just do it for
the motivation of sales because now in
the Future No One's Gonna buy the next
Kia for fear that this might happen
later the name is getting tanked because
the stain dragged in the mud already I
don't I don't think again I don't think
you should sue Kia because I really
agree with you that like yeah they
[__] up but they you weren't owed that
they didn't nobody knew that that could
happen because definitely when I see a
key I'm like it's probably but it's
[__] sales wise and PR wise yeah yeah
so everybody's got to do something right
so like he's got to fix this [__] and
also like maybe the [__] punishment
for getting caught stealing cards needs
to like get intensified well that's
that's our problem yeah I also do think
that with Bart's example if you don't
put a label on that helmet saying don't
do avert jump off the Queen Mary yeah
that's on the helmet maker
[Music]